Merry Christmas everybody don't mind my
Christmas sweater I don't know why you
would mind it it's delightful see I've
got spider-man on there as well I don't
know if you can see that I won't call it
an ugly Christmas sweater though because
it's actually a beautiful a beautiful
sweater and that's what I don't like
about the whole ugly sweater trend is
that I don't think the sweaters are ugly
I think that they're wonderful sweaters
and I and I would wear them all the time
if it was if it was socially acceptable
alright so Kyler Murray University of
Oklahoma quarterback won the Heisman
Trophy over the weekend which is a huge
accomplishment for the young man I'd
imagine one of the best moments of his
life as it would be for anyone to win
the Heisman Trophy and I guess that's
why the media felt that they had to ruin
it they they saw that somebody was
having a good moment that they were
getting attention for a good reason and
they said wait a second we can't allow
this let's let's let's turn it into a
negative story so USA Today among other
outlets but I believe it started with
USA Today and their reporter reporter
Scott Gleason decided to run an article
hours after Murray's big achievement
reporting on the homophobic tweets that
he he sent when he was 14 years old I
don't know what the tweets were it
doesn't matter I don't care I didn't
look they said that the tweets involved
him using homophobic language with his
friends so I assume that he jokingly
referred to one of his friends as a as
an F word and the slur for gays I don't
know but who cares it doesn't matter he
was he was 14 he was 14 even if he had
said it last week I still wouldn't care
but he said it when he was 14 offensive
language from a fourteen-year-old boy
does not matter there is literally
nothing that could make it matter if
it's your 14 year old boy and you're his
mother
or something then yeah I can see why it
would matter to you that you would
reprimand him and say don't use that
language
but in terms of the the news quality or
the the newsworthiness it has none it
has zero in fact it's less than zero in
this case because this is this is
offensive language from a
fourteen-year-old boy six or seven years
ago now I want you to look at the way
that this is phrased because here's the
first paragraph of the USA Today piece
hit piece about Kyler Marissa's Heisman
Trophy winner Kyler Murray had it had a
Saturday to remember but the Oklahoma
quarterbacks memorable night also here's
the part the memorable night also helped
resurface social medias memory of
several homophobic tweets more than six
years ago that's an interesting way of
phrasing is it it helped to resurface
social medias memory of homophobic
tweets from six years ago helped
resurface
so they phrase it almost like the tweets
literally resurfaced almost like they
floated up from the bottom of the ocean
and then washed ashore like if you ever
remember that movie the mask the Jim
Carrey movie from the 90s it went with
that with a magical mask kind of gets
jostled loose from its from its chest
down at the bottom of the ocean and it
floats to the top and then it washes
ashore and for some reason Jim Carrey
picks it up and puts it on that's kind
of the way you you almost have something
from the way that's phrase do you have
something similar in mind as if the
tweets were contained in a magical chest
at the bottom of the ocean and so in a
whale bumped into it or something and it
made it float to the top and then and
then it washed ashore and somebody was
walking along the beach and just
stumbled across it and said oh what's
what's this oh looks like offensive
tweets from a fourteen-year-old boy
let's I must go I must go alert the
masses no that's not the way this worked
this this was not a passive process
someone had to go looking for the tweets
and how did that someone whether it was
Scott Gleason or whoever else how did
they find the tweets what method did
they use to to look for them well they
could have combed through six years
worth worth of tweets to see if they
could find anything but that's probably
not how it was done that'd be a little
bit inefficient and in fact the way that
they really did it is in some ways maybe
worse because what they would have had
to do is they would have had to plug in
Cuyler Murray's name to the Twitter
search bar and then also put in you know
the f-word slur for gays or they would
have had to come up with a few offensive
words and just plug it in to see what
comes up to see if Tyler Murray ever at
any point in his life used those words
on Twitter and they would have done this
just because he won the Heisman and and
for no other reason someone would have
had to say or multiple people in the
media would have said well this guy won
the Heisman let's go see if he ever
insulted gays that's that is literally
the thought the thought process that's
that's the way it would have worked well
he he's in the news for a good reason
let's go see if we can find a reason to
destroy him and then what do you know
they found it mission accomplished
now we can destroy him because because
because why because he dared make the
news for a positive reason because he
dared accomplish something you know
people often complain that the media
never reports good news well or they
never report we report the positive news
and it's if it bleeds it leads right at
all they don't focus on the good stories
well it's actually worse than that
because what they do is it's not just
that they only report negative stories
it's that they they will turn every
story negative so they'll take even a
positive story and they'll turn it into
a negative instead of doing a story
about this exceptional young man and his
great achievement they decided to report
on the language he used when he was 14
it's not as it's not as though there
weren't other interesting angles they
could have gone so it's not like they're
saying well yeah you won the Heisman but
I mean how much can you really say about
that the guy won the Heisman right we
need more we need more content okay for
you if you're looking for more content
about Kyler Murray how about the fact
that he just won the Heisman as a
college quarterback but he's already
been drafted by I think by the by the by
Oakland I think to play professional
baseball so this is a guy who just just
won the Heisman but and he could go play
professional football buddy's gonna play
professional baseball so that's how good
he is at two different sports that's
interesting I didn't even know that
myself until I looked him up today I
don't really follow to call it college
football that closely and I looked up I
said wow that's interesting how about
doing a story about that I mean this guy
could play either one of the sports
that's a to be that talented in two
different sports that's an interesting
angle it's an interesting positive
uplifting angle nobody gets hurt no
one's destroyed it's just why not report
on that instead if you're looking for
Kyler Murray content how about that what
position is he gonna play in baseball
how good is he at baseball what don't
you know these are all things we could
talk about if you're looking to do a
Kyler Murray story but instead you say
no let's talk about his tweets from from
seven years ago so what is this what's
the point why why do this why do this to
people
part of it is political of course as
always there's always a political
element part of it is about buttressing
the the less victim narrative but I
think it's also just that there's also a
lot of simply pure malevolence pure
maliciousness involved even putting
politics and ideology aside a lot of it
is simply destroying people for the sake
of it just because for entertainment
it really is the modern version of the
Colosseum I know that that analogy is
maybe overuse but it really is in this
case it's like the Colosseum except it's
less honest because at least back in the
old Roman days you would go to the
Colosseum and you would watch two
gladiators kill each other or you would
watch someone get ripped apart by lions
whatever it just a nice day out with the
family nice nice wholesome family
entertainment and and that's what you
were doing there was no there was no
hiding it you were going to the
Colosseum to watch somebody get ripped
apart by lions so if you were if it was
a date night with your wife and you got
a babysitter you would say hey honey do
you wanna I heard they got a couple new
lions and they've you know that the guy
down at the marketplace that was just
arrested for trying to steal an apple
from the produce stand they're gonna
he's gonna be ripped apart by line do
you want to go watch you know let's go
let's go get something to eat and we can
go watch the guy who ripped apart and so
it was everyone knew that's what they
were doing there was no hiding it but
now it's kind of the same thing where
people like to watch a person get ripped
to shreds in a different sense have
their reputation in their lives ripped
to shreds we still like to watch that
except that we can pretend that that's
not what it's about we can pretend that
we it's it's not entertainment for us
this is about justice it's really it's
really a it's a noble thing we we can
pretend even that we have some sort of
righteous anger at this person because
oh this is this is this is justice they
said something terrible six or seven
years ago so it's not as honest that's
my problem with it it's not on it at
least admit you know if you're going and
you're combing through somebody's tweets
to see if they ever used an
inappropriate word so you can throw it
against them after they've just achieved
something then at least admit that
you're doing that because you think it's
fun to destroy people that's all at
least in minutes have have a certain
amount of honesty
the courage of your convictions and
admit that's what you're doing okay
there's another story I wanted to
mention here briefly from The Daily wire
it says this week a Virginia high school
teacher was fired because he wouldn't
use the preferred pronoun of a female
student who claimed she was now a male
the unanimous decision from the five
members of the West Point School Board
fort to fire Peter flaming a French
teacher at West Point High School which
is roughly 265 students followed a four
hour hearing the board only discussed
the case for an hour before rendering
their decision blaming had taught at the
high school for almost seven years had
taught the student in question in the
2017 school year when the student
identified as female then over the the
summer of 2018 the girl decided that she
was a boy so she went you know she left
school in the 2017 to 2018 school year
and she was a girl and then she came
back and she said actually I'm a boy so
this school year
flaming addressed the girl by the new
name she had chosen so he he did use the
new name a names a name you know you can
choose any name you want for yourself
but he would not address the girl by her
preferred pronoun because it conflicted
with his Christian faith the student
went and complained and and processes
were carried out and then finally the
guy is fired the school board wrote a
statement and it says in part we do not
and cannot tolerate discrimination in
any form or actions that create a
hostile environment for any member of
our school family mr. flaming was asked
repeatedly over several weeks and by
multiple administrators to address a
student by the pronouns with which this
student identifies the issue before us
was not one mistaken slip of the tongue
tongue mr. Vaman consistently refused to
comply going forward a willful violation
of school board policy while we
understand that some do not agree with
our decision we hope that our
discussions blah-blah-blah-blah-blah all
right only it's just one thing I want to
say about this and that is the
is actually not really about mr.
Fleming's Christian faith that that is
included in this it's true that as a
Christian there's no way as a Christian
that you can use someone's preferred
pronoun if it is not the actual pronoun
that's attached to them grammatically
because a pronoun is not like a name you
don't get to have your own pronoun you
don't own the pronoun it's a pronoun as
a matter of grammar there are certain
grammatically correct ways of referring
to a person depending on their
biological sex and that's that's all it
is so this is a matter of biology and
grammar pronouns that personal pronouns
those that is a that is a convergence of
biology and grammar and so it's got
nothing your own preferences and desires
have nothing at all to do with it that
is not part of the convergence it's just
your biology and then grammar you don't
decide your biology you also don't get
to decide grammar all of these things
have already been decided and so that's
what that's where your personal pronoun
comes from so it's true that if you're a
Christian you could not possibly use
somebody's preferred pronoun if it's not
the real pronoun because that would be
dishonest and as Christians we are
forbidden from telling lies but it isn't
just Christians who would say that lot
that lying is wrong this is really
simply about honesty this is about truth
and honesty plain and simple no matter
what your religion is doesn't matter if
you're Christian Jewish Muslim doesn't
matter doesn't matter if you have no
religion if you value truth and honesty
then you should be on mister blaming
side because that's really I I think it
is not a good thing it's not going to be
it's not going to help us progress on
this issue and and restore sanity to
this issue I should say it won't help us
do that if we turn this into a religious
thing if we turn this into a Christians
verse
ever religious liberty that's not what
this is this is not a religious issue
you don't need to be Christian you don't
need to believe in the Bible to
understand that women are women and men
are men and you don't get to have your
own pronouns because grammar is grammar
and you don't get to decide for yourself
you don't need to be Christian to
understand that this this is a this is a
universal thing this is just truth and
honesty that's all and so if you value
truth and honesty which hopefully every
Christian does but also hopefully
everyone else in the world would too
if you value truth and honesty then you
you would have to be a mr. blaming side
and you you couldn't possibly use
someone's preferred pronoun if it's not
the correct pronoun because you are then
participating in a lie you are telling a
lie unless you don't know it's that it's
not true but if you know it's not true
and if you know that this girl is a girl
and you refer to the girl as a him that
is a lie a lie is a willful deception it
is when you willfully tell it's when you
willfully intentionally say something
that is not true she is not a him so if
you call her him then you have said
something that is not true you have told
a lie and that's all it's not that the
school board was trying to make mr.
flaming betray his Christian beliefs
although they were trying to do that as
well but even before that they were
trying to force him to tell a lie they
they said that if he wants to keep his
job he has to tell a lie and he got
fired simply because he wouldn't tell a
lie that's that's what's going on here
all right one other story I have to
mention this one in the in the live feed
from the International Space Station you
could see a blue and white object of
this was this was last week the
International Space Station has a live
feed where you can go and check it out
and see what's going on with the earth
at any given time well last week
if you're watching the live feed you
would have seen a blue and white object
appear in space and then hover over the
earth and then as soon as it appeared
the feed went down okay now obviously
that's gonna people are gonna start with
the conspiracy theories when you when
you see that but as usual with these
kinds of stories because I read that
story and I and like you I was super
excited so that I went and I watched the
footage and it's always a letdown I mean
every single time you hear about a was a
mysterious object was seen in space and
then you go and look at it and you say
well that's just like that looks like
just a smudge or something on the on the
lens of the thing or looks like looks
like light to refract refracting from
somewhere or whatever it doesn't really
look like an object so I went and looked
at the feed and it I don't know what the
thing is but it doesn't even look like
an object it's obviously some sort of
illusion although it is suspicious that
the feed went down as soon as the thing
appeared so who knows maybe it was
aliens but probably not but every time
you see one of these the you know it
brings up the conversation of well do
you believe that aliens exist is there
intelligent life out there and I find
that question to be to be almost absurd
because the answer is so obvious let's
just think about this there are we
believe about a hundred billion galaxies
in the observable universe so a hundred
billion galaxies ingest the little
sliver of space that we can see and who
knows how much space there is outside of
that one hundred billion galaxies now
our galaxy the Milky Way has about a
hundred to 200 billion stars and most
stars have planets around them so there
are probably a couple of trillion
planets in just our galaxy and if there
are you know let's say a trillion or so
planets in every galaxy then that means
it's like 1 or 2 trillion times 100
billion and whatever that number is 2
trillion times 100
whatever that number is that's how many
planets probably exist in the in the
universe
so even if the odds of an intelligent
you know of an intelligent civilization
and intelligent alien civilization even
if the odds are let's say 100 billion to
one or even a trillion to one that would
still mean that there are billions or at
least millions of planets in the
universe with intelligent civilizations
which means when you look at the numbers
it's it's not even like an interesting
question of course there's intelligent
life out there it is it is pretty much a
mathematic certainty that there is
intelligent life out there when you
think about the the vastness of outer
space and no matter how you look at it
whether you're looking at this from a
supernatural perspective or a natural
perspective because if you don't believe
in God
well then you've got this we got a
hundred billion galaxies life arises
randomly even if it's even if it's
extremely rare that life arises when
when you look at just the numbers that
we're dealing with even a very rare
occurrence has almost certainly occurred
billions of times but if you believe in
God and you're going to say that there
is not intelligent life in the universe
then what you're saying is that God
created a universe with 100 billion
galaxies and trillions of planets and
then put no but putting nothing on those
other planets except ours which seems
absurd why do all these galaxies exist
do they exist just to look pretty in the
sky that seems like that's a lot of
effort to go through to create entire
galaxies so that we could see pretty
things when we look in telescopes it's
hard for me to believe that's the only
reason the galaxies exist but so we know
that intelligent life exists in the
universe it's it's I think we call it a
certainty but we also know that the
closest solar system to our own is about
four light years away which is I think
about 20 or 25 trillion miles we don't
have anywhere close to the technology to
go those distances the andromeda galaxy
which is our next-door neighbor in terms
of going in galactic terms that is three
million light years away if a light if a
light year is five trillion miles
then that's three million times five
trillion miles so what does all this
tell us it tells us that there is almost
certainly intelligent life in the
universe and we know that because of the
size of the universe but it also tells
us that we will almost certainly never
find it ever because of the distances so
it is a humongous universe with tons of
stuff in it but everything is so far
apart that we will almost certainly
never come in contact with with the life
it's just it's out there but we will
never come in contact with it kind of a
kind of sad and depressing but I think
that's simply the reality all right um
one other thing I don't know why I was
thinking about this but before we wrap
up I have to tell you one thing that
annoys me and I know it's surprising to
hear that I'm annoyed by something but
hear me out something you see online a
lot and I I just saw this yesterday so
that's probably what I'm thinking about
it but something you'll see online a lot
especially on Twitter and Facebook is is
this thing where people post pictures of
their dogs allegedly doing something
cute and then they'll have a caption
that says something like we don't
deserve dogs or what did we ever do to
deserve dogs have you seen that you know
talking about it's become kind of an
internet meme almost we don't deserve
dogs now in general I always feel
nauseated by this groveling that people
do to their pets oh oh we aren't worthy
of you dog oh oh great dog
we aren't worthy we are we don't deserve
you dog oh great dog it's it's kind of
sad because we should have more pride as
a species but but more than that I have
a dog okay I feed my dog I walk my dog I
clean up my dog's poop I buy him toys I
take him to the vet he sleeps all day
and never lifts a finger or a paw to
help with anything around the house he
doesn't do anything he doesn't he does
not help at all
with anything so if anyone is failing to
pull their weight in our relationship it
isn't me I mean if anyone doesn't
deserve anyone else isn't it more true
to say that dogs don't deserve us what
do you mean we don't deserve what else
could we possibly do for these animals
to deserve them we do everything for
them so if anyone doesn't deserve anyone
isn't it the other way around dogs are
the most privileged animals in the whole
animal kingdom they get treated like a
royalty we spend literally billions of
dollars on them the other day I walked
outside of my house and I saw a raccoon
eating out of my garbage can and that's
what life is like for wild animals life
is short and cold and miserable and they
eat garbage and then they die
and when they die they are consumed by
scavengers or bugs that that's what it
is
that's what it is for a wild animal now
my dog eats garbage too but that's just
because he's a glutton it's not because
we don't feed him dogs have it so much
they have it better than any other
animal they are so dogs are so lucky
that then they were domesticated and
that we have this affection for them
they are so lucky they they they're the
luckiest animals on earth so I'm just
saying
dogs have much
better than any other animal to say we
don't deserve them makes no sense to say
we don't deserve to have these pampered
creatures lying on our sofas that
doesn't make any sense
so listen this is my message to my
fellow humans I'm not saying you should
hate your dog and not saying you
shouldn't have I have a dog too okay I
like my dog but this is this this is
about self-respect as a species okay
we need more self-respect as a species
so here's what I want you to do when you
go home tonight I want you to walk into
your home go right up to your dog and
say listen Rex you don't deserve me I'm
the king of this house and only by my
generosity do you survive you should be
thanking me and then take him outside
and clean up his poop with a plastic bag
like a slave but all through that
process remember who you are never
forget you you are the master you are
the human being and we need to reclaim
pride in that it's okay to have pets but
we have gone way overboard with with our
pets and there's so much better than us
to look at these animals there we are
nothing compared to them oh my gosh do
you think these animals are saying that
about themselves no they have pride in
themselves your dog is saying I'm a dog
I'm great so you should say the same
because we we own the planet okay I mean
we won the species lottery we we
achieved the most self-respect all right
that was my pet does my very weird pep
talk for the day and I'll talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed